uh today we're actually going to be
talking about astronomy and we're really
lucky to have professor meg yury here to
lecture to us and professor yuri is one
of the most popular professors at yale i
think it's fair to say she's absolutely
adored by the students she actually came
to yale in 2001
has been here about six years now and
before that actually worked at the
organization that ran the hubble
telescope which i think is very cool so
beyond being a phenomenal scientist and
having i think it's 125 publications at
last count and huge impact on the field
she's also a phenomenal person and the
mother of two daughters aged 12 and 15
which is pretty extraordinary as well so
enough of my sort of summary we should
really let professor yuri talk because
she's going to give us a great lecture
today so let's have a hand for professor
yuri
thank you very much
well it's really nice to be here and see
such a big crowd coming out saturday
morning this is great thank you for
coming i hope you like the story i'm
going to tell you
it's about how the universe is expanding
faster and faster and
and how this the story of how we figured
this out this is very recent stuff i
mean astronomy is a very old science
of course growing up in new haven or the
vicinity you might not realize but used
to be when you went outside the first
thing you noticed was the sky filled
with stars so people for thousands of
years have
wondered about
the structure of the universe and what
those things were and so on so astronomy
is a very old science but um
although we sort of thought
about 10 years ago if you had asked an
astronomer
you know what's left to discover
they would have said we knew we know
pretty much everything we've really
pretty much figured out the universe i
think my first slide
shows um this is our picture of what's
hap what was happening in the universe
how we got to where we are today there
was some kind of initial very rapid
expansion sometimes you hear it called
the big bang
and sometimes you hear it called
inflation
and the universe expanded from smaller
than the size of a nucleus to you know
macroscopic scale and then it it grew
and gravity very slowly operated over
time
so that tiny fluctuations in the
universe initially grew into
clumps this is a picture of the sky in
the microwave background radiation
cosmic microwave background for which by
the way two friends of mine just won the
nobel prize about a week ago
um for this discovery
and then over even more time this is at
about it when the universe was a few
hundred thousand years old
but over the next you know
dozen billion years
uh gravity made these clumps grow into
what we see today which is galaxies uh
stars within galaxies
so
astronomers really a decade ago thought
they kind of had this whole thing sussed
out and it was just a matter of getting
the details right
and what i'm going to tell you about
today is basically we were all
completely wrong and we had missed the
biggest elephant in the room and this is
the story of how we figured it out okay
so before i begin the full story i want
to give you a sense of the size and
scale of the universe and this is this
diagram is meant to convey
um
the immense scale that we're talking
about and for for me at least it's hard
to think about so this let me let me
take you through this whoops this thing
doesn't work well on let me do it this
way
hang on okay so in the lower right you
see the hubble space telescope picture
of the hubble it's about 10 meters long
okay that's about the length of this row
of chairs or if you like it's the size
of a school bus
okay
if i multiply that length by a million
i get the side of a cube which would
enclose the earth so the earth is about
10 million meters across roughly very
roughly
now i multiply by a million again and i
get to the size of the solar system
okay the solar system is about 10 to the
13th meters across
now
this is where i start to lose
lose uh the understanding you know 10 to
the 13th meters to me doesn't mean a lot
so let's so another way of thinking
about this is
it would take light about 10 hours to
get across the solar system from one end
to the other and you know light travels
extraordinarily fast so for light to get
from one side of the solar system
together about 10 hours
okay let's multiply now by a factor of
about 10 000
and we get to a cube that encloses the
nearest stars
so our neighborhood of stars in our
galaxy and
those are all a few light years away
that means the light from those stars
reaches us a couple of years maybe five
ten years after it was emitted from the
star
so far so good
okay
now i multiply by another factor of ten
thousand
and i get to the size of our milky way
galaxy which is a spiral galaxy much
like the one in this picture
we um we live in the suburbs in this
galaxy we're out here about two thirds
of the way out from the center
which is good for us because the center
is filled with gamma rays and x-rays and
things that would sterilize probably
sterilize at uh
our planet if we were closer in
and this this cube now you can think of
as about a hundred thousand
light years across
so it takes about a hundred thousand
years to send a signal from one side of
the galaxy to the other
now if you've been watching the news at
all lately you know that
there all these stars in our galaxy and
they're about about uh let's see
100 billion stars in our galaxy
many of them have planets and probably
many of them have planets like the earth
so there might be lots of life out in
our galaxy but just think about how
you're gonna you know you aren't gonna i
am them because
if you uh you know if you wanna send a
message to one of these creatures on
another plant it's gonna take tens of
thousands of years to get there
and then you gotta wait for the reply
okay
now we just multiply by a factor of a
hundred
and we get a cube that encloses our
local group of galaxies this is our
neighborhood of galaxies these guys
there's some big ones like us we're a
big galaxy there's another big one
called andromeda these are a few million
tens of million light years away so
those are pretty far
but as far as the universe is concerned
they're very local
very local
and now we multiply by a factor of a
thousand
and we get to the scale of the universe
today
you can see this 10 to the 26 meters
that's about 10 billion light years
the age of the universe is
we now know very precisely is 13.7
billion years since that initial big
bang
and so you can basically see out about
13.7 billion light years any farther
if if indeed there's universe farther
away
we can't see yet because light hasn't
had time to reach us
most of what i say today is is sort of
on these scales on the very largest
scales of the universe
the most distant galaxies and
the the biggest structures in the
universe
now i like it when people ask questions
is there anything here that you want to
know more about or isn't clear
so a lot okay so the question is if the
universe started as a point initially
what was outside that point
this is a question that we all ask and
that's a little bit difficult to answer
because um
there was
not necessarily anything outside it okay
we're we're thinking with
three-dimensional minds about a point in
three-dimensional space like a little
point over here that's not where i am
okay
but initially everything all of space
was inside that point
so let me make an analogy in two
dimensions that's easier for us to think
about okay
imagine that you are an ant
and you live on the surface you live on
a two dimensions so you can go north
south east west but you can't go up down
you only have the two dimensions to move
in okay
and now imagine that you live on the
surface of a sphere like a little ball
so as far as you're concerned you don't
know it's a ball because you don't know
about the third dimension you just know
there's a surface okay
now that ball gets bigger it expands so
as far as you're concerned your space is
now much bigger because it's the surface
of a big thing instead of the surface of
a little thing
but but if i asked you what were you
expanding into
since you don't know about the third
dimension you wouldn't answer you would
have no way of answering that question
so i'm pleading a little bit that it's
impossible to answer the question you've
asked because we don't really know
there might be other dimensions there
might not but we what we have to think
of is everything you know all the people
you know the atoms molecules you're made
up of you know the wood your house is
made out of the whatever
things you know were inside a subatomic
size point at the beginning
surrounded perhaps by time who knows
yeah
right so is there any evidence now that
we've reached the edge of the visible
universe and the answer is emphatically
no
we have seen very high redshift objects
as you say things that are very distant
but we expect if we have more sensitive
telescopes we will see still more
distant objects number one and number
two we know that if looking only at
light
from these early objects we can't see
let me go back
uh oh i have to sorry sorry
you know the arrow keys work much better
there we go
okay
this picture of the cosmic sorry i keep
catching on the hinge um the picture of
the cosmic microwave background here
this is the lat as far as backwards we
can go so this is a 13.3 billion years
ago that's as far back as we can go and
the reason is before that
light didn't travel in straight lines
because the universe was so hot it kept
scattering and so we can't see past this
with our telescope we can see past it
with gravitational wave detectors and
that's one um
uh
detectors that will see gravitational
events in the past and that's one of the
things nasa is trying to do yeah
yeah the age of it is 380 000 years
after the initial big bang so it's
uh that i'll answer after the talk is a
little bit off the topic so let me go on
okay so now we uh we know the scale of
the universe so now i'm going to start
the
the bread and butter the meat and
potatoes of this talk
first of all how do we even know the
universe is expanding
okay we're in the middle of it we're the
ant on the surface of the sphere how do
we know
and i'm going to tell you there are two
ways we know
one of them
has to do with these two guys these are
two engineers
arnold pinzayas and robert wilson who
were working at bell labs in the 1960s
they they had a
they were interested in building a very
sensitive radio antenna that means it's
essentially the equivalent of a
satellite dish today it's shown behind
them here here's a better picture
uh it's the equivalent of a satellite
dish if you like to receive radio
radiation from space
and they wanted to make it
extraordinarily good very very quiet
that means that the only things they
would detect are radio waves from space
they wouldn't have any hiss or or static
noise from their electronics
and since they were good engineers and
they were working at a laboratory that
was interested in making telephones
quiet for example they knew how to do
this
however they found when they finally
finished it and they pointed it at the
sky that no matter where they looked on
the sky they found noise
they found a sort of low level hiss
and in fact you can see this hiss on
your television if you tune it between
channels you know how there's kind of a
well if you have cable you don't ever
get between channels you're old enough
before cable
if you tune it between channels you get
this kind of staticky noise that's what
they saw and they assumed because they
saw it in all directions okay evenly
that it must be in their instrument
if it belonged to the sky they reasoned
they should see it brighter in some
directions and fainter in other
directions so they were sure it was
their fault
so they tried everything they knew
to fix it including this is a great
story there were actually you know this
is a big antenna there were pigeons
roosting in the antenna
and the pigeons that pigeons as pigeons
will do they leave behind
you know dung pigeon dung
and they worried that that stuff on the
surface of the antenna was maybe
causing this
signal so they took the whole thing
apart they scrubbed off the pigeon poop
they put it back together
but they still had exactly the same
result look all over the sky they see a
signal
what happened was they talked to some
people down the road at princeton
university and they realized that what
they were observing actually did come
from the sky
it was the remnant radiation from the
initial hot dense universe
and they were detecting it and of course
it was the same in all directions
because the universe was fairly uniform
uniform initially and so these two guys
won the nobel prize for that discovery
in 1978 and that may have been the first
nobel prize for astrophysics
so that was a really important discovery
that the universe had once been small
and hot and dense and was now large and
cool
and so it must have expanded and must
still in fact be expanded
now um
the second reason we know there's an
expanding universe is actually a little
bit earlier evidence
and that comes from a guy named edwin
hubble
and it's based on his hubble law so i'm
going to explain the hubble law to you
the hubble law basically says that when
we look at galaxies distant from us
more distant than our local group of
galaxies we find that the speed of the
galaxies
moving away they're all moving away from
us
and the more distant galaxies are moving
away faster
and it's exactly proportional speed is
proportional to the distance now
i'm going to explain to you why that
tells you the universe is expanding okay
and
i also have to explain how we measure
speed and how we measure distance
because you can't you know you don't get
your radar gun
and bounce it off a galaxy because the
galaxy's tens or hundreds of millions of
light years away maybe billions of light
years away so you have to find a way to
measure its speed and how so how do we
know how far away they are so we get
that from the brightness let me explain
those ideas
first of all
if you had a light bulb that you knew
was 100 watt light bulb
and you moved it twice as far away from
you it would be one quarter as bright
that's called the inverse square law
it's basically light falls off as the
square of the distance if you moved it
ten times farther away it would be a
hundred times dimmer
so the trick is if you know the light
bulbs wattage if you know it's a hundred
watts
and you measure how bright it appears
you can tell how far away the light bulb
is okay that's what we try to do in
astronomy we measure the apparent
brightness
and we have some way of knowing the
luminosity and that lets us figure out
the distance and
knowing the luminosity is is what we
call a standard candle
a candle of a fixed power and it turns
out there are few objects in the
universe that operate as standard
candles that means
there are certain kind of objects that
have all of them seem to have the same
intrinsic luminosity and if we know that
luminosity then we can measure their
distance
questions about that
that's okay
okay
now speed we measure from something
called redshift is there a question
about the previous yeah
it's a very good question and we
basically have to study
in the in the case i'm going to tell you
about we use something called supernovae
so a supernova is the explosion of a
certain kind of star at the end of its
life it's extraordinarily powerful they
become very bright in our galaxy there's
one about every 300 years
and there hasn't been one in our galaxy
in about 400 years so we are due
we are due for a supernova and if you go
out some night and see some
extraordinarily bright star that wasn't
there the night before that's probably a
supernova somewhere in our galaxy and
that actually happened in 1987 in a very
nearby
tiny galaxy this astronomer who was
taking a break from his observing in
chile went outside he was kind of
looking around and he said wait a minute
there's a star up there that didn't used
to be there because he was smart enough
to actually know what should be there
which i don't think i would uh
and he he had discovered a supernova in
the nearest galaxy anyway those
supernovae
the particular kind of supernova that we
use as standard candles
are the explosions of stars of a fixed
mass
certain kinds of stars end up at a at a
mass of a little more than the mass of
our sun and they're very hot and dense
they're called white dwarfs and when
those things explode they all seem to
give off the same amount of light
and so we use those as standard candles
okay redshift
now
astronomers all the time are measuring
something called a spectrum
and the spectrum of say a star
means its intensity the intensity of
light as a function of the wavelength of
light
short wavelengths are bluer long
wavelengths are redder
and these features that i've sketched
here these are what we call lines
emission lines or absorption lines and
those are emitted by elements that we
know about we can reproduce these in the
laboratory we know the wavelengths at
which they should appear
but sometimes
you find that the spectrum these lines
appear at the wrong wavelength
they appear typically at a redder
wavelength so longer wavelength the
whole spectrum is shifted
and that shift to the red which of
course we call redshift
is proportional to the speed with which
the object is moving away from us
and that's very analogous to
something we are familiar with
when you hear
you hear the sounds from a moving object
say a fire engine coming toward you
has a higher pitched siren than when
when it's moving away from you and
that's a very similar shift of
wavelength when an object is coming
toward you
the wavelength you measure is shorter
the wavelength your ear hears is shorter
the frequency is higher you hear a
higher pitch when it's moving away from
you the wavelength is longer it's
stretched out and you hear a lower pitch
so that's what happens with light and
and we can measure this redshift and we
can infer the velocity the speed with
which an object's moving away so that's
how we do speed and brightness
this guy
this guy he famous astronomer well not
that famous like moderately famous
astronomer vesto slifer
i feel he succeeded just by doing
anything because that name is really a
tough burden to carry
so he was an astronomer who observed
that when he looked at galaxies they all
seem to be moving away from us
now copernicus had taught us a couple
hundred years earlier
that the earth was not the center of the
universe so why should all
galaxies be moving away from us from our
milky way galaxy that seemed a little
odd to him
and
it takes a little bit of thinking and
that's what i'm going to explain to you
about the expansion of the universe so
first let me just
sort of reiterate this a galaxy moving
away from vesto had a redshifted
spectrum
very few uh galaxies were moving toward
the observer and were blue shifted
so hubble
took this observation and his own
observations of similar galaxies these
two facts most galaxies are moving away
and he also noticed that the more
distant galaxies were moving faster
he plotted the speed against the
distance and he found that the data fit
a very nice tight line
and he realized that meant uniform
expansion of the universe
now that's the step that i don't know
about you but i had trouble with so i've
made a cartoon that will illustrate it
imagine
space which for our purposes i've made
very uniform here's a grid okay so at
every grid point i put a galaxy see all
these galaxies of course space is a
little more
non-uniform than that but this will
illustrate what i want to show you and
imagine that every galaxy is a distant d
from its nearest neighbor
now let's let space expand by 30 percent
okay now space is bigger
the galaxies are still sitting at the
grid points but now they're 1.3
d apart 30 percent farther apart so far
so good
okay
okay now this this grid is infinite i've
only drawn a piece of it that can fit on
my powerpoint slide but it's infinitely
large
any piece of it
could be
us
so let's just say we're here in this
galaxy
okay
and now i've color coded it so that
we're this galaxy in the white box here
are three galaxies in blue boxes that
are one grid point away
okay
here are two galaxies in green that are
two grid points away from that guy and
here's one in yellow that's three grid
points away okay
now let me calculate how far did each
galaxy move from me milky way white box
okay
the nearest grid one that the galaxy's
nearest you know that were 1d apart or
now 1.1.3 d apart so they moved point
three d
okay
the one that's two squares away
moved
from two d to two point sixty so it
moved point sixty
and the one that was three squares apart
move 0.90
so the farther the galaxy was the
farther it moved from whichever one i
pick is the center
and if i calculate the speed with which
they move they all move in the same time
speed is just distance over time
so if the speed of the first galaxy was
well of course it's the distance over
time if i call that v for velocity then
the speed of the second one is 2v and
the speed of the third one is 3v and i
can plot that on a graph of speed versus
distance and i should get a perfectly
straight line
and that's what hubble realized the fact
that he got a straight line when he
plotted speed versus distance meant that
this universe was expanding uniformly
now i know this is a lot to absorb for
people who've never heard before so i
have a little demo let me have my
volunteers come up you can face that way
if you want
so imagine these guys are galaxies and
they're tightly packed in the early
universe
tightly packed and then
over time they expand
so let's see you expand and let's have
this galaxy be the middle of the
universe okay one arm's length away
okay and let's expand some more
okay you see how the more distant galaxy
has moved the farthest
and the nearby ones have moved less far
so if if this astronomer is measuring
the velocity of that galaxy
that one has the largest velocity and is
the most distant
thank you very much we have a hand for
the
demo
thank you okay so that's how expansion
gives you this hubble law
now what now the reason i took the time
to tell you all this is because i want
to now give you the
the punch line about what astronomers
discovered at the end of the 20th
century and they did it with a hubble
diagram so i'm going to show you their
actual results
first of all they don't plot speed
versus distance for some reason modern
astronomers oh sorry
sorry i forgot i had this slide this is
just what hubble did he plotted the
actual speed versus the actual distance
and this shows real data and the line
that fits them
but these days instead of speed versus
distance which i'm reminding you speed
we get from the redshift distance we get
from the brightness
modern astronomers plot distance versus
speed i don't know why
it's the same line but i just flipped it
okay
and in fact
okay we'll talk a little bit more about
this
this line works for a uniform expansion
okay so the whole universe is expanding
at constant at a constant rate
if the expansion were slowing down
then you would expect
a curvature in this line
when you got to large
speeds you would find the galaxies had
not gone as far as they could have
had you been going at a constant rate
because the rate's slowing down
so you would see curvature like this
and in fact what that means is objects
are closer okay they're less distant
than they would otherwise be and
therefore objects objects are brighter
now modern astronomers are looking for
this effect
because they said
the universe is filled with matter
you know there's you me the earth and a
ton of stars
there's a lot of material and that
material exerts gravity on the other
stuff
and that pulls inward
so if the universe is expanding outward
it ought to be breaked
it's there's a breaking effect of
gravity it ought to be slowing down
and they figured that if they measured
that they could figure out how much mass
was in the universe so they expected to
see this slowing down trend if they went
far enough out
now one more thing about the plot they
tend to plot it detrended so they they
divide by this line here
and they ask
you know am i on this line or below it
or above it and
so it's a horizontal plot they make this
is the difference from the hubble law
okay
are objects more distant and fainter or
are they closer and brighter
and here's the constant speed line
okay
and slowing down i remind you you should
be closer you should be below this
horizontal line slowing down is below
the line brighter closer up standard
candles
okay
so
how do we weigh the universe oh question
how do we know all galaxies are moving
and we aren't moving how do we know that
all the other galaxies are moving and we
aren't moving
um it all depends on your frame we are
moving okay we are participating in the
overall expansion of the universe and
even if the universe is infinitely large
any part of it if you if you sit in any
part of it the hubble law will apply
just as i showed you with these guys or
with the grid you can sit on any galaxy
and you'll measure the same hubble law
because all galaxies are moving away
from any one of the other galaxies
okay
okay another question yeah
yes actually we do know what speed we're
moving at in the cosmic expansion
because we can measure it relative to
the microwave background i don't
remember the speed actually but i'm sure
it's
it's it's probably um in the range of
hundreds to
to thousands let me think of kilometers
per second but i i should know the
number i don't but we're all we're
moving in many ways right the earth is
rotating the earth is orbiting the sun
the sun is orbiting in the milky way
galaxy and the milky way galaxy itself
is moving so it's actually quite
complicated we're moving all over the
place and very fast too amazing you're
just sitting here
calmly
oh can we collide with other galaxies
the answer is yes we can
now i should say
space is mostly empty if you wanted to
approximate the universe
the easy the the simplest thing you say
is completely empty i mean
it's very empty so between galaxies
there's not much and galaxies are far
apart however gravity
even though it's not that strong a force
it has had a very long time to act and
so in fact there are regions where the
galaxies have pulled quite close
together
and where they are in fact colliding
now it's not like luckily you colliding
with your neighbor or your car hitting
another car because the galaxies also
aren't that dense
and lots of the stars just pass by each
other there are very few times when the
stars themselves will actually bump into
each other and have a i mean that's very
unlikely so mostly what happens is the
stars pass through each other but the
gravity
the the gravitational forces between the
two galaxies tend to rip the galaxies
apart so if we were in a collision with
the nearest galaxy and i should tell you
the nearest big galaxy andromeda is
coming toward us
so sometime we will collide with
andromeda i forgotten the estimates but
it's billions of years in the future you
don't have to worry
um but it will destroy our galaxy what
will happen is we'll collide with
andromeda and we'll make a new galaxy um
and if there were still life on planets
in the solar system in the solar system
or some other solar system in the milky
way then i'm not sure whether it would
survive or not but it might
there's another question here yes
oh so if all the galaxies were like
coming together how do they go apart
again
good question so if two galaxies are
moving toward each other and remember
they aren't like hard objects that are
going to bounce off each other they're
going to pass through each other they
don't really stop they keep going
but gravity initially gravity is pulling
them together okay but once they pass
through each other then gravity is
actually trying to stop them from going
away gravity wants to pull them back
together
so if the gravity is strong enough
they'll come back together and they sort
of oscillate they sort of come in and
then they do this and then they end up
kind of
as one big ball of stars
okay there was another question here
yeah
isn't it more likely for the sun to blow
up in a supernova so the sun will
will pass out long before these other
effects occur it's true uh and but the
sun's not going to be a supernova
because it's not massive enough to start
with so the sun our sun
our sun is like you know middle class it
is it is it is
like most of the stars in the galaxy not
too big not too small sort of like you
know just right not too hot not too cold
and it's gonna puff up at the end of its
life in about five billion years and
then it's just going to kind of
you know wimp out settle out burn away
and be a small dull thing
it's not going to be a big thing yeah is
it possible to refuel the sun with
hydrogen is it possible to refuel the
sun with hydrogen well the sun is 99
percent of the mass of the solar system
and the planets are the other one
percent most of it's in jupiter so
nobody's got enough hydrogen to refuel
the sun
unfortunately yep
yep
how do we know that the hubble law
applies to the whole universe
well what we can do from the earth is
map out where every galaxy well at least
the ones we can see where are the
galaxies and what are their velocities
and then we can make a three-dimensional
picture which really doesn't depend on
where we've measured it from okay
because we know the absolute velocity of
this galaxy
relative to us and we know our absolute
velocity relative to the cosmic
microwave background so we can put them
in the in a fixed frame of reference and
we can ask where all the galaxies are
moving and how and where they are
relative to one another and that's where
we can see that this expansion picture
works on average yeah what is the source
of energy
okay so i'm going to get to that that's
the dark energy part let me okay we have
a couple let uh
i don't want to keep you guys too long
so maybe can i can we hold the questions
and i'll just go to the punch line which
which this question was about and then
we'll come back and i'd be happy to
answer questions all morning long
actually okay so astronomers set out to
weigh the universe
and their idea was we'll measure the
rate of slowing down of the expansion
and the way we do that is we look at
very distant galaxies which have
supernovae in them and and we measure
them
and then how much it's slowing down will
tell us how much mass is in the universe
if they slow down a lot there must be a
lot of mass in the universe if it's not
slowing down hardly at all there's not
much mass in the universe and that was a
key
a key measurement this is what i mean
about getting the details astronomers
were sure they just kind of needed this
detail and then they would be done with
the problem
okay let me tell you what a supernova is
this is a picture of a galaxy before a
supernova goes off in it
here's the same galaxy afterwards you
see this point of light here
right there that's the supernova okay
i'm gonna go back
it's not there
and now it is
okay and that's a supernova in this
galaxy it's easy to measure when the
galaxy's more distant it's harder
here is an example of another supernova
this is a movie
so the supernova is going to go off
right about here in this galaxy you'll
see it get bright and dim in this movie
and at the same time you'll see this
what we call a light curve this is the
intensity of light versus time so you'll
see the supernova as time goes on gets
brighter and reaches a maximum and
decays in brightness till it's much
fainter this light curve is a
characteristic
of the supernova this is what lets us
get the distance because its brightness
sort of you fit to this shape and the
brightness tells you
uh how far away it is and this is the
spectrum which i talked about before
intensity versus wavelength that gives
us the red shift so if you can measure
these two things from a supernova then
you've got let's see i can get this
movie to go
hello okay
nope
sorry do it on here
okay so you see the supernova go off get
bright get dim
and
astronomers can measure it
before and after let's do it one more
time there's the supernova there's the
light curve there's the spectrum so
that's experiment is you find these guys
you measure them
and uh you measure their speed and their
brightness and the more mass there is in
the universe not you and viewers the
more expansion should slow down the
closer and brighter the supernovae
should be yes
that light curve yeah good point the
movie was not in real time that takes
weeks
and if for the more distant ones it
takes months and the reason for that is
because time slows down
the redshift cause a redshift in time
also
so things happen slower when you look at
very distant supernovae it takes much
longer for them to go up and down
due to the expansion of the universe
okay so in 19 in the early 1990s two
teams set out to a measure this quantity
two separate teams uh west coast uh
physics-based team at lawrence berkeley
lab east coast astronomer based team
mainly at harvard but also actually also
with some west coast pretty
international both of them i show this
picture because they were shall we say
competitive
and um
it was good there were two teams because
the result was so wacky okay they use
the hubble when i was there i used to
run the
the proposal reviews to see their
proposals all the time they were quite
competitive they'd write these things
saying only we know how to do this
the reason hubble was important was
because it has very high spatial
resolution that means they take it takes
extraordinarily sharp pictures and this
just shows you a comparison of a galaxy
with a supernova observed from the
ground it in with pretty good
uh seeing that means not much
atmospheric smearing and here's the
hubble picture of the same galaxy at the
supernova this is the galaxy okay and
here's the supernova
and you can see with hubble it's very
easy to see the supernova and measure
its brightness from the ground it's very
difficult
okay and they looked out at galaxies
in the distant universe this is the
hubble deep field this is the deepest
picture taken of the universe
at the time which is in 1995 and off
just off in this direction
a supernova happened
here and i'm showing you how we find
these things so that's the picture i
just showed you was about here so here's
this little
area where there's a supernova
blown up here's the supernova if you
if you take this picture of the sky
taken in 1997 and you subtract the
picture taken in 1995 or vice versa i
actually forget which one the supernova
was in you get this this is the
supernova it was there in one epic and
not in the other and this is how you
find supernovae here are three more
examples
here's a galaxy before a supernova
here's the galaxy with the supernova
same thing galaxy before a supernova
here's the supernova so if you just take
lots of pictures of the sky you can find
these things and you can follow them and
do the experiment
okay so i've already telegraphed the
answer they found the wrong answer okay
they're supposed to find
objects are closer and brighter
here's what they found remember
horizontal line is constant expansion
slowing down their points should be down
below that blue line
and look their points are up above the
blue line
and you know when they first saw this
they thought okay we've done something
wrong
and they went back and they looked at
their data and they tried to see about
the calibration no and then they checked
with the other team that's the reason
there was there were two teams and both
teams were finding this with different
supernovae you know measured differently
and so on so they were convinced they
were right
and this means that the
expansion of the universe is speeding up
it is not slowing down
gravity should be slowing it down so
there is some other thing
some
you know anti-gravity which is pushing
galaxies apart we call that dark energy
and the discovery of dark energy which
i'll talk about a little bit more
was called the the science breakthrough
of the year in 1998
um
later if you ask me later i can tell you
why it was called einstein's greatest
blunder redeemed
and um
it really probably was the most
important discovery of the century in my
view because it was
it told us there was some new physics we
had not even thought about
so we knew about the forces of gravity
of electricity and magnetism
the weak force that keeps nuclei
together the strong force that keeps
protons together those are the four
fundamental forces of nature and they've
been the four fundamental forces of
nature for 100 years
and now we found some other fifth thing
not only that but the fifth thing
well we call it dark energy
energy because it's some kind of extra
energy that's making things fly apart
okay
dark is code it's astronomer code i tell
you right now for we don't have a clue
what it is
okay so there are other dark things you
may have heard of dark matter it's a
completely different thing because all
because dark matter causes positive
gravity but the dark word means the same
okay means we don't have a clue what it
is so uh we don't know what it is we
really don't know what it is we don't
know how much there is well we do know
how much there is i'll tell you that in
a second we don't know what causes it or
how it behaves how much there is is why
it's important
from additional measurements we have
learned that dark energy is the dominant
constituent of the universe
three quarters of the mass energy
density of the universe is dark energy
another 20 some percent of it is dark
matter this other stuff we don't know
about only four percent of it is stuff
we know about like atoms and
uh hydrogen and so on
so
most of the universe
is stuff that we only learned about in
1998
and it's causing our universe to fly
apart faster and faster
sometimes people ask what will happen
to our universe and the answer is until
we understand dark energy i can't tell
you
but here are some possible scenarios
if
um if dark energy stays about like it is
now then the universe will expand
indefinitely okay and and continue to
accelerate if dark energy gets stronger
than it is now we could have a scenario
called the big rip
where
dark energy gets so strong that it even
rips apart galaxies and eventually stars
and everything else
or maybe dark energy gets weaker in
which case gravity
because it's patient will eventually
cause the universe to re-collapse so we
don't know yet
we're trying to measure
the
history of expansion of the universe to
try to constrain what dark energy is i
just wanted to show you one of our
telescopes this is a yale
yale has part ownership in this
telescope on kitt peak in arizona
near tucson if you're ever out there in
tucson or phoenix you can drive down to
the mountain and go up and see it this
is the inside of the dome
our telescope there and we're using this
to measure
to take pictures of the universe
to learn about
these things that we really need to
learn more about in order to understand
our universe today dark matter dark
energy and i couldn't resist adding
black holes because although i didn't
talk about it that's what i mostly work
on so um so the answer is
you may think you understand everything
about a particular area of science
you may think we fully understood
i don't know chemistry biology pick your
favorite but you can you can set out to
make a routine measurement and find that
you really didn't have a clue about
anything and maybe for a student in
middle school that seems like a bad
thing because you suddenly know you you
know you you've learned about your
ignorance but for a scientist it's
actually extremely exciting because it
means that we have something new to
learn about so so actually when we found
we were completely
off track it was a great thing for
science so so we're very excited about
this and we're keen to figure out what
it is and you know come back in 10 years
and i'll tell maybe maybe in 10 years
we'll know a little bit more thank you